[Applause]
you had a guidance counselor
i had a guidance counselor this is where
the title came from i had a guidance
counselor who when i was 16 years old
you know you they sit you down and they
tell you uh they ask you what do you
want to do when you when you grow up and
i said i'd really like to be an actor
and a filmmaker and then on the side at
some point i'd like to do something in
public service she laughed at me and she
says well you can't have your cake and
eat it too which i sort of thought was
super weird that is that's your guidance
counselor advice to a 16 year old not
inspiring did you not watch sesame
street hopes and dreams and all things
are possible let's all be together well
guess what you made it a reality
okay so your time in the white house one
of my favorite stories is um tell me
about your moment on air force one
and the thing that you got to do when
you were on it so the the um the the
wonderful things about working in the
white house and i was a junior staff for
mid-level staffer depending on how you
kind of looked at it and every so often
there's a little perk like uh in one
case i was putting together an event for
president obama he was meeting with
young republicans young democrats and
young independents in boston good as
well
it was a great great conversation uh and
on the way out you know i was when
you're a staffer you go early you put
the event together and then
the boss comes in and leaves and then
you go later on take the train back to
dc or whatever and they said hey we've
got an extra seat on the plane do you
want to come i'm like on the plane
on air force one the plane
yes i would like to take that
opportunity please so you go on the
motorcade you get on the plane each seat
has a phone
um and obviously that's for official
business but one of the perks i guess
over the years is that you you know you
can make one quick discreet phone call
to somebody you love in your personal
life just because it's kind of cool to
say that you're calling from air force
one and so do you just pick up the phone
do you have to like slide a credit card
you pick up the phone this is a good one
thankfully you don't have to slide a
credit card you pick up the phone and
there's an operator and the operator you
tell the operator the number you're
calling in the person you're calling and
they connect the call and when they
connect the call they call the person
you're calling and they say hello mr mrs
so-and-so uh i'm uh you have a call from
air force one
please hold on that's so cool
it's awesome
well that is a perfect transition to
your hot mess holiday which i'm so into
from the title tell us about it so this
is a a movie called hot mess holiday for
comedy central comes out on december
11th
and it's about these two women played by
serena jindal and melanie chandra two
hilarious ladies from here in new york
and it's a it's a diamond heist movie
but it's also a holiday movie about
diwali the the uh
the holiday that symbolizes light over
darkness so you have like
a plot that's similar to bridesmaids if
i if i may be so bold and i kept
pitching it in the room i'm like you
know what it has like it has hints of
bridesmaids there's a lot of tiffany
haddish in there for me and they're like
in what way it's a diwali movie about a
diamond heist i'm like just trust me
they're so funny and then you know they
put together the trailer and we shot the
thing and it came out and you're like so
happy with it yeah it's really fun the
title of this movie
has all the feels for me hot mess
holiday it just sounds like a good ride
i want in i'm excited to see it i love
del valle i'm excited to celebrate that
through this film and i'm glad that you
are bringing this to us thank you for
that thank you so much and by the way
in the world of david sedaris who helped
us realize you know and great old films
like we can laugh through the holidays
too because they're triggering for some
people they get really heavy lots of
pressure comic relief
and entertainment
is so key and crucial at this time of
year one of my favorite holiday movies
is national empoon christmas vacation
the best
everything that can go wrong
everything that can go wrong goes wrong
in that movie and there are elements of
that in hot mess holiday and i i have
been trying to figure out how to explain
it you just put that into my head by the
way i had forgotten that comparison
because so many things do go wrong in
our own lives there's stuff you're
hanging out with your family or your
chosen family or neither and the
thoughts you have during the holidays
especially if you're drinking a little
is very real and so it's fun to bring
that to life on screen
i also
am amazed at how you have come out into
the world and inspired people whether
it's by being an actor or in public
service someone who's bringing
representation and now you are engaged
yeah um to josh yeah thank you thank you
i'm so happy for you thank you so much
and
it's the stories it's the things that
you have fought to tell and you've
brought other people along on that
journey and you have inspired people in
fact we have two people right here in
our audience who are huge fans of yours
and
they wanted to say something to you
it's um raj and priya raj i'd love to
start with you um thank you so much for
coming today thank you nice to meet you
nice to meet you i've been the kumar to
a few heralds in the past and i love
hearing that and um you know it's
congratulations on your book launch i
read it it's amazing as well as your
engagement and you definitely have
inspired people it's really important i
have representation and i actually came
out to my parents 41 hours ago
that's awesome i'm not kidding
that's so great auntie and uncle
congratulations
how did it go
it was went better than i ever expected
um they were both
i wasn't surprised they weren't
surprised because i did you know bring
someone to my sister's wedding so they
kind of you know put two and two
together but they just said you know
what uh we love you we support you and
we're very proud of you um and you know
also you should you should settle down
soon that's wonderful congratulations
what i love about parents parents
parents will always find a way to you
know yeah i could have used some of that
priya
it's so nice to meet you nice to meet
you too thank you so much cal i've been
a fan of yours since like american daisy
you've been oh wow a south asian
diaspora icon for years and just you've
inspired people just as drew said by
being who you are and so as a queer
south asian now just to like welcome you
publicly to our community is like you to
see that example is still so rare in our
community of someone who's at peace with
themselves and finds happiness in their
own lives
you know and comes out when they're
ready publicly but also just like has
their life and together you know and
like perseveres through all that you've
been through so thank you for for
everything that you do and thank you
this is so sweet thank you so much
to both of you you know i
it's it's such an interesting thing
my
uh josh and i've been together 11 years
and and of course we've you know he he's
he like my parents have met all of our
co-workers and friends and there's no
there's no timeline on what what to
share or when to share i i actually was
a bit naive in thinking
that was the easiest the easiest chapter
in this book to write about is the
person that you're going to marry all of
the harder stuff is like okay how hard
did you have to fight to get your foot
in the door what was it like working for
the first black president like those are
all the emeritus things so i just have
to say how wonderful it is to hear your
stories and thank you so much for
sharing them well i'm very excited for
your and josh's nuptials
pending and just thank you cal for
everything that you've brought to the
forefront with your life your parents
must be so proud oh thank you i
appreciate it they're watching now so
thank you what an amazing job you've
done what an incredible son you have
thank you raj and priya and
is out now and be sure to watch his
awesome film hot mess holiday premiering
saturday december 11th on comedy central
i'm there for that
[Music]
you